thousand oaks california an affluent
suburb outside of los angeles
akira and lisa were a young married
couple when they moved here more than 20
years ago from the bay area while lisa
raised their young family akira worked
at a popular and trendy japanese
restaurant called sushi cow in the
wealthy suburb of bel air
in the beginning i was a sous chef my
kirk learned the art of sushi making in
japan he was good at his skill and so we
started working at sushico in bel air
and the restaurant just took off and
just became super successful
my dad was a great chef he was so
excited and he was cooking every year we
increased the sales then i become a
manager then owner yeah yeah this is a
girl from sushko we decided it was time
to venture into our own bigger and
better and nicer sushi
hello welcome to sushi we decided to
open our restaurant this beautiful
shopping center in thousand oaks
in the beginning business was
booming then it just slowed down
like somebody put the brakes on
it's pretty devastating to him
it broke him
it's tough yeah
anybody walking around out there no i'm
pretty quiet even if there's nobody in
here akira will scramble
to find somebody to do a job for him
hannah could you get the drink over from
table one yeah food is up and that
irritates the crap out of me make sure
you guys have everything okay most of
the time now my dad just kind of walks
around he doesn't like do anything
they're going to turn off the electric
you have to pay that one we are losing
like 15 to 20 000
a month credit card debt is hundreds of
thousands or as deep as you could ever
imagine we still are like 9 000 behind
living with financial stress is pretty
bad did you send somebody for two or
three i gave it to them my parents are
always like fighting and arguing and
that's a [ __ ] nightmare
never used to be like that
over the past four years akira and i
have grown apart we work together and we
live together but we don't speak to each
other it just isn't worth it
my dad doesn't spend enough time with us
he's just less approachable
dad how many older not just one i don't
really ever talk to him anymore
dad
akira's spirits are broken down and he
just doesn't know what to do anymore
life has been like hell well since we
opened the restaurant
if sushi will close tomorrow i think we
could lose everything our house
restaurant and
our hope and our dreams
i can't remember the last time i slept
through the night she's always worried
about what's going to happen next
shepherd is our last hope
[Music]
hello hi welcome to sushi girl i'm lisa
lisa nice to see my daddy and akira
akira what's the connection
business partners
my lovely wife are you married to each
other yes
and you're the chef
why it was i'm a manager now i do not
cook much anymore okay and lisa you run
the i'm kind of the front of the house
lady greet the guests right serve tables
if needed what is the problem with sushi
we do not have enough guests clearly
there's no guess but what's the problem
the main problem i do not know you know
we stand in the window and dance trying
to get people to come in here
and that that hasn't worked around here
i'm so embarrassed i can be able she
does the front of the flamsy so tell me
about uh sushico i had a lester in
berlin so then you brought out the other
partners and bought the name pretty much
so yeah and then decided to sort of move
sushi code from belair to your hometown
here and thousand oaks exactly so how
long did it open here it's almost four
years four years um i can't do anything
unless i find out what the problems are
so
i'd like to eat uh what would you
recommend um if you wanna try something
fusion i have a
sushi pizza which is sushi pizza
japanese pizza
i don't i don't like it
wow
i'm not a big fan of any of our food
there's just like no flavor anymore
because the cure is not involved enough
in the kitchen
okay well i'm gonna sit down have lunch
i'll look forward to catching up with
both you after lunch thank you i enjoy
lovely thank you
[Music]
some strange
fixes on the wall
are you ready yes please
thank you uh right
let's start with a little miso okay and
um akira mentioned the sushi pizza he
recommended that yeah i wouldn't
recommend it no no i would not recommend
the sushi pizza to
anybody uh i think it's vile gotta try
the sushi things though just out of
curiosity good luck
good luck
and the green tower that sounds nice and
then let's end up with a little bit of
the summon just see me i think that'll
be enough you got some of the best and
some of the worst thank you thank you
excellence
some of the best and some of the worst
no one's afraid to share their opinion
here
for your soup thank you
here we go
[Music]
miso soup doesn't taste very fresh
it's not actually very hot either
oh he's talking now somebody should go
listen to what he's talking about
thank you chef your green tower thank
you that's very salty that does that it
is yeah is that normal yeah that's
normal
thank you thank you
[Music]
so much
[Music]
um
are you finished with the green tower
and it's just i pulled out this
disgusting hair
yeah
yeah i've definitely finished with that
sorry
i just wanted to
just die bury my head in the sand when
that happens um
guys
there's
a hair
in the green tower you gotta be kidding
me
it's always like a running joke like oh
my god there's a lot of things going
wrong so akira disappears
yo sashimi
thank you you're welcome
and is the salmon fresh yes it is thank
you
[Music]
john
the salmon is fresh right
frozen frozen
[Music]
it just tastes
like it's frozen how does your sashimi
that's definitely frozen it's very very
chewy my mistake i was just informed
they are frozen they tasted frozen is
that normally
the way they're freezing
i guess we get lazy with our food
[Music]
yeah i've never been to japanese
restaurant where i can have a
sushi style and a chef owner that's no
longer in the kitchen
i'm nervous just go with it okay
um
that's the sushi pizza it sure is it's
rice salmon crab and mayonnaise some
cheese wow thank you
japanese pizza
[Music]
that
is rancid
you were right
that is an insult to pizza yeah and
japanese food
chef had fair warning that it was going
to be terrible
i told him not to get it
where's the chef
the old sushico always stood for the
finest in japanese food
but today's disappointing lunch proved
to gordon that the only thing this sushi
ko has in common with the former one
is the name did you know there's a hair
in the crab no no no one told you
hair are they wearing hats back here
you asking me yeah
are you guys wearing hats for service no
no nothing at all no
if you're telling them what to do why
can't they wear a hat
i don't know
oh jesus let's go back to the beginning
when was the miso soup made it was made
yesterday yesterday and just tell me why
was something that tastes salty he's
probably been sitting in there reducing
overnight would you mean reducing
overnight you keep stuff in the memory
overnight correct
what
the
sushi pizza was a [ __ ] joke right
okay
hideous disgusting and an insult to
japanese culture and an insult to a
[ __ ] pizza house wow
you don't need me to come in here and
tell you you look [ __ ] stupid selling
a sushi pizza that tastes like
gunk what were you doing serving frozen
fish to me lunch time
i would like to order proper fresh fish
and
it doesn't actually happen i've never
known a japanese ration to free so much
stuff
i'm not here to make you look stupid
but i can smell [ __ ]
okay can you say something
seriously
talk to me
talk to me
what do you want mean
[Music]
after getting very little out of akira
chef ramsay decides to sit down with the
owner's children 22 year old sammy and
20 year old hannah
was it always a plan to have both of you
so involved from day one
it was an idea for us to come help and
give them a break if they needed to but
not to be here
every weekend
i
most of the time don't even want to be
here because i'm here so much but you
got to do what you got to do yeah i'm
going to help out the family and here's
my worry honestly it's the level of
shortcuts that are currently going on in
this restaurant right has your father
given up
yeah i think he definitely has on the
inside but he doesn't want to show it do
you ever tell him to just stop
take stock
rethink
he doesn't really listen
[Music]
please don't get upset i'm sorry no no
come on i just uh yeah yeah
i know it's telling her i totally get it
i'm almost 21. it should be
living my own life but
i can't because i have to help my wife
my family and i can't leave them
you're both incredibly committed and i
you know totally respect that level of
loyalty and what i'm more nervous about
than anything is the state of the
business where do you see the business
pretty much as far down as you can go
i've also recently like in the past year
given money also
and is it mum that comes and asks who's
my dad that asked so initially i gave
ten thousand dollars and then half a
year ago he asked for five thousand and
i was like of course you know how um
from working my photography my own
personal income if your family's asking
me for help i would help them right away
i have
probably given my parents above 20 000
decent chunk of change
for a 22 year old i think
there's a level of
unfairness
because you've both been dragged into
this through no choice of your own
you've got my help
i'm supporting every one of you
my family is hanging by a thread
there's only so much i can do
[Music]
in the short time that gordon has been
at sushi co he has not only learned that
the restaurant is in shambles but that
this once tight-knit family is suffering
badly
hi welcome to sushi how i'll take you
back to your table
[Music]
enjoy your dinner
what can i get
[Music]
you don't buy them by that do you
why they burnt we re-use them sometimes
it was we wash them clean them they use
them again
i can't believe this is happening
i wash the stick and everything is clean
what's the program where's lisa i i know
kyra don't run away like a snake okay
i'll just scrape dried chicken off these
we're cutting fast there's bits of food
on there
do you think this is right
just feel how sticky that is on the end
that's food being wiped off
[Music]
it's 45 minutes into service and sushi
co is doing what unfortunately it does
best
disappointing its customers
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
lisa it's coming back it's doughy and
that's not tempura broccoli
it's mushy yeah
[Music]
stop the broccoli take it off yeah don't
even like temper anymore why cause more
damage
is that frying hot enough does it work
probably the frying temperature uh
actually that's a great question it
doesn't look it's hard enough it's not
blasting it no
that's scary
that's a nightmare piece of equipment
that probably isn't holding the
temperature because it's getting old
just like me
uh lisa here look at who it
so you don't keep mayonnaise in the
fridge we're not that's not required for
liquidation
what that's i had refrigerate after
opening
see how warm that is
and how long has that been staying
outside for
truthfully always seeing ourselves spicy
for four years yes
this is a japanese health hazard
this is about you running your
restaurant properly
and you're
not oh my god what's this fridge for
it's warm in here this fridge is on 50.
this work in this fridge well it broke
down when did it break down a couple
months ago i don't have the money to fix
so we've got big containers as ice yes
to keep the ingredients cold well just
the vegetable we keep it here vegetable
we got dairy you've got eggs here that
that's a mistake never chicken beef here
look at me
well sometimes they make a mistake
i'm not lying to you i can't you should
kill somebody
[Music]
bad food a family in ruins and
unsanitary conditions you should kill
somebody
it's been quite a first day
and as dinner service ends thank you
chef ramsay realizes that sushico is in
much worse shape than he thought
right
how's that for you
i think our kitchen could have run a
little smoother
[Music]
i don't think you're taking it seriously
enough
the rice the soup the fridge
the broccoli
talk to me
i think that
akira
you know could do a lot more
there's so many bad practices
and you don't seem to give a [ __ ]
have you given up
i think he's given up
how many of your customers would order
kushiyaki if they knew they were eating
it or feeling it off a wooden stick that
had been used three weeks ago
none of them
[Music]
it's almost like you're a man in denial
anything to say or no i should he
doesn't know how to fix it though he
opened this place
on the assumption that he was the
delegator he's lost
i think that the restaurants burnt him
out he thought that we were going to be
live in la vida loca and when the
business didn't go the way it was
supposed to he didn't know what to do
obviously but you don't really think
that you're lazy right you think you
work do you think you work really hard
all the time i said i think you should
go cook you go to woodacook anymore
that's the way accurate feels if if i
can pay you to do it why should i do it
but you're not really paying them your
kids are paying them
he doesn't know how to get off of his
little skinny ass and really getting to
work right
i need you to shut up for two minutes
and i need you to talk
this is part of the reason
why you've lost your voice
not only is your wife wearing the
trousers but she's speaking for you
what is it
talk to me
[Music]
come on
talk to me i've just uh
i don't know
come on akira [ __ ] me
basically i don't know what to do
i'm angry that akira's lost his ability
to communicate with people
and
it was good to get it out
akira once a proud chef has lost his way
and unfortunately his family is being
dragged down with him chef ramsay knows
that in order for this restaurant to
have any chance of surviving he must
find a way to bring them together
tough day yesterday uh really tough i'm
outside the family home now and it's
clear that akira is a broken man and in
order to get this restroom fixed i need
the old akira back so
i can't do that without the family's
help
[Music]
i just wanted to talk to all three of
you um about
akira he's a broken man a man with
a tremendous weight on his shoulders
this is a man that is
not just on the edge the whole family's
involved in this you can feel the divide
just in terms of the friction that's
built between you every day every second
take me back when you first met
[Music]
um he was really funny and cute
he had a lot of energy and he used to
think of goofy things to say even though
he didn't speak english very well and
he never smiles anymore yeah
so sad yeah it's so sad
dad's just kind of away from everybody i
think he's removed now he's not like a
part of the family really it's just
always just me and the kids and he's
just gone he'll just like stand and just
stare because he doesn't know what to do
he's
he's lost i miss like
when he was just smiling when i walked
in the door yeah
we need to bring him back if that
russian's got any chance of really
seriously turning around it can't be
done without him no i know that i can't
do it without him he's the heartbeat i
need each and every one of you to gives
him a
a lift
in a way that
his self-esteem
rises the confidence starts to shine and
more importantly we start to get him
back
[Music]
i think my dad he's checked out i can't
remember the last time i saw him like
actually happy like waking up happy
going to bed happy i wish he could come
back and make it all right
oh hey chef ramsay where have you been
on the lake oh well you know i was just
taking a walk i didn't know you know my
house yeah i know and while i was asking
me here i wanted to come and um see
where it all started there's a level of
distance that we've grown apart
we need to narrow the gap
sammy you go first
what inspires you most about dad
working on from dishwasher to
restaurant owner
he always he's always when it tells me
to get it right the first time i learned
all my hard work from him so
yeah it's just tough you know like i
want to do as much as i can
it's just it's just hard i know i'm
putting out the weight on you so i'm
gonna try harder
okay
now you will
you believe them
thank you sami
honor if there was one thing
that you would want to say that you've
never had the chance to do
over the last four years what would it
be
[Music]
i don't think i ever tell you how much i
love you i like i say i love you but i
never really express it
[Music]
i love you too
i just want to see you happy
my family is really suffering
[Music]
i want to try to be more emotionally
supportive we want to support you and we
want to do everything we can it would be
a dream just to
be our old selves again
let's pretend that we
were starting out and like let's try to
find each other again and be friends
i feel really happy but a little sad too
because it put my family in a
bad situation here today we are going to
start it fresh we wipe the slate clean
we start the day with a family hug
[Music]
way stronger
i think you know
i can do it this time
i can list that argument
[Music]
the emotional family meeting really
touched chef ramsay and he made
arrangements to give akira and the
restaurant some much needed help
i decided that this
family needs
a little lift a little leg up i've never
been into any japanese restaurant i've
seen a fridge with a block of ice in
there that broke down four months ago so
i made a few phone calls and managed to
get hold of seven
brand new counter trollson refrigeration
units allison top of the line yeah come
on have a look
come around yeah that's right that's the
best
one you can get yeah uh trust me number
one
come around
nowhere look come round lisa
open the map
he's smiling
oh my god the fridges to me are amazing
they're beautiful they're great i can't
believe it but to see akira's face when
he heard out about it was the best
because that's the only time i've seen
him smile in four years i didn't stop
there come with me
yes
have a look at
two stunning vulcan d fat friars oh my
god
[Music]
the most amazing to walk in freezer
temperature is visual no more ice bucket
when i saw this kitchen i thought it
wasn't my kitchen looks like a shoulder
everything's brand new it's like a
dream now we have no excuses great
[Music]
new equipment is just part of chef
ramsay's plan
he knows there's another critical change
that has to be made at sushico it's an
asset they should have taken advantage
of a long time ago tonight
you're gonna cook okay it's a comeback
service okay okay
but i want you to
grab it okay and run with it all right
how you feeling being great same way to
cook
[Music]
okay
good
hey kieran today he's going to help
oversee tonight's launch at the sushi
bar
okay please welcome the man himself back
look at you
look at you
see my dad and his chef suit was really
exciting the sushi bar is where my dad
belongs it's where he started off and he
was a great chef before and he's getting
back in it so that's great okay lisa
open the door
hello welcome to sushi cow it's me too
for dinner service not only will they be
serving fresh fish
chef ramsay prepares with akira two new
salmon dishes that will be featured on
tonight's menu
hello how are you tonight are you folks
ready to order i'll have the chicken
there we'll try the sushi coke crunch
okay
so you can see atlantic salmon i'm gonna
make that okay
okay
i'm so excited about being behind the
counter we have a lot of good fish today
so enjoy okay
all right
i'm gonna have a great time today to
rainbow chiang beach and crunchy breeze
i don't think sure is taking it
seriously
even though we are starting to see a
glimpse of the old akira shining behind
the sushi bar all right thanks for
waiting chef ramsay notices that his
wife lisa is not supporting him could
you take this out for two or five please
have some food for you guys right here
[Music]
i like it
i still don't think he's working very
hard we got too much fish out there okay
okay yeah let me know when you're lazy
i'm gonna apply the oil okay okay thanks
for double checking on everything is he
working hard i don't think so he's still
just walking around i'm worried that
akira is not gonna ever be the chef that
he should be take this and come back
right away i don't think he'll really
follow through with it
oh all right there's some share plates
and sweet dishes is there supposed to be
avocado in it yeah did they put avocado
no
they didn't
[Music]
and this is supposed to be a hawaiian
roll with the shrimp on top instead but
it's a california roll
that's a nightmare
akira the eel roll's supposed to have
avocado inside that eats hawaiian sauce
okay all right
really pisses me off
elise is really talking with akira when
she gets going just get out of the way
it's like a tornado
that's my mistake i didn't check that's
for mala thank you
no two or five feet or two or six you'll
see so i have to try harder it's gonna
be a next order spider tuna capacio
someone special
it's avocado shrimp on the top thank you
and the rolls yeah
yeah thank you
i'm so glad to have a hero back behind
the bar it makes everything go so much
smoother okay scott done done done all
right
this is incredible
standing behind the bar dressed as a
chef running his restaurant already
there's a completely different feel to
last night's service
sesame oil kind of cooks on that dish
it's our enjoy okay
watching my dad work in the kitchen and
smiling almost the whole time it was
just great feeling thank you very much
getting better
as dinner service comes to an end it's
clear that sushi co has a long way to go
but the new equipment akira's new
attitude and a couple of new dishes have
chef ramsay feeling better about its
chances first of all let me be really
blunt uh with you yeah and something you
you need to hear okay yeah
honestly yes
tonight
you were a different man thank you
the change is night and day i feel like
i woke up not only did you look good but
you seemed to look like you were
enjoying what you were doing
i've got total respect for you today
yeah appreciate it good job hey are you
a quick chat with your wife
i can't forget anything chef lambda
taught me i have a hope but i know i
have to really really work harder
now he may have changed
but unfortunately you haven't
the difference
in that man in 24 hours is night and day
and not once
tonight did you mention anything to
him and you can't be that [ __ ] cold
like a block of ice
he's not your head chef
he's your husband yeah
and here's the thing you're tough you've
been through a lot and over the last
four or five years you've become
stronger than he has
coming from the outside in
it's so evident
you're [ __ ] bang bang bang
back off
i'm not [ __ ] around
i'm not gonna take all the blame but i
agree that i am a [ __ ] to akira and i'm
i agree that it's not a good way to be
i think between you and i that man needs
you more than ever before i'll talk to
what you need to do is cut him some
slack
not just for him but for the family's
sake
before it's too late
[Music]
after chef ramsay's conversation with
lisa that man needs you more than ever
before and with akira's commitment to
change i feel like i woke up gordon and
his team went ahead with a much-needed
makeover of sushico
good morning look at you two holding
hands and cuddling as well
chef ramsay pleaded with me to embrace
akira and try to give him the support he
needs so this is a really crucial point
in our lives it's like being reborn
again
okay today we're re-launching the new
sushi co so we have to bring sushi ko
into the modern era the decor has to
stand out as something not just cutting
edge but fresh with a wonderful appeal
are you ready yeah yeah my hands are
sweating let's go baby let's go come in
look at that
contemporary and it's got that really
fresh appeal to it oh my
god shaking
goodbye samurai warrior the minute you
stepped in this door great colors it's
fresh and modern all that nice stunning
i felt like you know what this is my
restaurant what is this you know it's
just an amazing oh my god
when i first arrived like sitting inside
a prison
now it's beautiful look at the color
dark moody red that's my picture
you have a serious artist in the family
but no one's ever ever shown him up
they're cool they're sophisticated
lisa are you happy i'm
so happy it's just amazing the color is
just perfect
[Applause]
ramsay is bringing us together as a
family
my parents
are like more happy than i've seen them
in forever
it's awesome
he's a new man
[Music]
[Applause]
after revamping sushi co into a stylish
contemporary japanese restaurant chef
ramsay moves on to the menu welcome to
the new food
have a look by modernizing their
traditional sushi dishes avocado tatar
with avocado crispy salmon cake see a
tuna with a salsa japanese style curried
mussels teriyaki chicken the rolls we've
got the fire roll clean modern great
execution
okay so we're gonna have a great start
today right
[Music]
word of the relaunch has spread through
the community and chef ramsay has
surprised the owners with traditional
taiko drummers to officially kick off
the evening
[Music]
[Applause]
and ladies and gentlemen thank you so
much for coming thank you
the official welcoming and the opening
of these questions
[Music]
my heart was pounding like you know
drunk it's so exciting brand new
restaurant brand new
me
hello
as the first orders make their way into
the kitchen you
make sure back him up okay and energized
akira pumps up the cooks for the big
night help each other talk to each other
okay
all right
first one of the night sushi cool crunch
bust one out
let us cup two more
sammy two fourteen sushi crunch
let us wrap that in the window okay give
it to me i need one more authentic
summer here 209
209.
the yellowtail roll
akira at his rightful place in the
kitchen pushes the first orders out
and customers are satisfied with what
the new sushico has to offer
but soon after old habits return and
akira is doing everything except what he
needs to do most cook
so i'll use fish earl please enjoy thank
you
hey thank you very much
i've been waiting for a special for half
an hour lisa the food's hanging around
too long on the window okay without a
leader the kitchen is falling behind
it's dying in the window and the impact
is starting to be felt in the dining
room you and i only had one ticket here
no
there's another ticket there's more
tickets there earlier tonight akira was
doing really well behind the sushi bar
but now he's falling back into his old
ways already he's out busting tables and
he's not paying attention to what's
happening we need him to be back behind
the bar again what are you doing
carrying that thing wow they needed the
help so i just i need the help
all right
honestly i'm worried
you went back to your old ways
you didn't cook anything
you bus tables you serve food you
delegated
why weren't you cooking why weren't you
can you not do it no i can do it you're
not a [ __ ] manager you're not a
busboy you're the chef
come on
[Music]
finally towards the end of dinner
service akira took chef ramsay's advice
okay
and jump back into cooking in the
kitchen
yeah thank you but for the most part it
was his staff who pulled together and
made tonight's relaunch a success thank
you
the good news about tonight is the
customers love the food oh yeah yes
this restaurant took a huge leap forward
oh yeah
oh yeah spreading the message out there
but i just want to know what you're
going to do
what's going to happen when i'm gone
i will remember what every everything
you told me
you are a talented man you've just
forgotten how talented you are
what are you talented for picking up
[ __ ] plates no why are you a talented
man cooking that's right so if you're
gonna dress it apart look the part
cook your socks off got it i'm not gonna
go leave the section
about the table or
not gonna do that
if i catch your skinny little ass that
side of the table i swear to god
but lisa you've got to support each
other
i came in i first arrived the whole
family not just the restaurant was just
fragmented four different individuals
seeking different ambitions with
different attitudes and no one's singing
off the same page but there's a
reconnect that's taken place there's a
level of clarity proper understanding
and we all know what we've got to do
they'll be okay you know it's tight
family you know so
we please we'll help each other
having chef ramsay come into our lives
is
it's meant the world yeah we have a
start over and i'm nervous as [ __ ] that
it's not gonna go smoothly and i'm just
am thankful for this new chance
take care thank you yes
good night thank you so much
[Music]
okay
bye
it was really cool to see my parents
give each other kisses and stuff
i haven't seen that in a while
working with each other and
supporting each other it's gonna give us
more hope than we had before
[Music]
what a week we made a lot of changes we
changed the equipment we changed the
menu and we changed the decor but what
this family fell to realize is that
their greatest asset was something i
could never have given them because it
was themselves and it's that that will
make this place successful
[Music]
what a week
sayonara a thousand oaks
in the days that followed sushico saw a
boost in business and lisa and akira
were working as a team once again
all right
let's clean up the prison yeah let's
clean the space up here recently they
decided that in order to maximize
profits they would search out a new
location where the rents weren't as high
you have anything anything special give
me a call
regardless of the location the most
valuable lesson this family may have
learned was not how to run their
business but how to appreciate each
other
you